let's multiply nine
times
eight thousand
and
eighty-five that should be a pretty fun
little calculation to do
so like always let's just rewrite this
so i'm going to write the 8085
i'm going to write the 9 right below it
and write our little multiplication
symbol
and now we're ready to compute so first
we can tackle 9 times five well we know
that nine times five is forty-five we
can write the five in the ones place and
carry the four to the tens place so nine
times five is forty-five
now we're ready to move on to
9 times
and we're going to calculate 9 times 8
and then add the 4 that we just carried
so 9 times 8 is 72
plus the 4 is 76. so we'll write the 6
right here in the tens place and carry
the 7.
now we are ready to calculate and i'm
looking for a suitable color
9 times 0
9 times 0 hundreds plus and this is a 7
in the hundreds place so that's actually
700 or if we're just kind of going with
the computation 9 times 0 plus 7. well 9
times 0 is 0
plus 7 is 7 is 7.
and then finally finally
we have i'm once again i'm looking for a
suitable color
9 times 8
9 times 8 this is the last thing we have
to compute we already know that 9 times
8 is 72 and we just write the 72
right down here and we're done
8085 times 9 is 72
765.
let's do one more example just to make
sure that this is really clear in your
brain at least the process for doing
this and i also want you to think about
why this works so let's try
let's try seven
times five thousand
five thousand three hundred
and
i encourage you to pause it and try it
on your own as well
well 5000 i'm going to rewrite it 5 396
times
7.
first we'll think about
first we'll think about what 7 times 6
is we know that's 42 put the 2 in the
ones place 4 we will carry
then we need to concern ourselves with 7
times 9 but then we have to calculate
that and then add the four
seven times nine is 63
plus four is 67.
so we get we put the seven down here and
carry the six
then
we have to worry about seven
times three
plus this six that we had just finished
carrying seven times three is 21
plus six is 27 so we'll write the seven
here in the hundreds place and carry the
two and then finally we have seven times
five
which is 35 but we have to add the two
35 plus two is
37 so 5 396 times 7 is 37
772.